this is a massive wake-up call that uh
is sounding yet another alarm bell as
though we hadn't had enough in the past
saying that the impacts of climate
change are now widespread and severe
from heat waves drought wildfires to
heavy downpours and coastal flooding
and of course the conclusion from that
is that
climate change is speeding up and we are
speeding up our solutions landscape but
not at the same speed as the damages so
we are far behind right and i know
um you did well to get any sort of
agreement at paris
but um is this a sign that that was too
little too late really
now actually the paris agreement
foresees that there is going to be a
decarbonization of the global economy
over the next few decades in fact the
final deadline there is 2050 for net
zero
what we have to do now is exactly what
the paris agreement states which is
every five years countries have to come
to the table
in the context of the new science in the
context of the technologies that have
been developed
the policies that we can apply and the
financial shifts that we can actually
accelerate
to register under the paris agreement
the new
efforts of emissions reductions that
they can undertake
that is something that is foreseen in
the paris agreement to occur
every five years this time at cough 26
is the first time that that mechanism
which is called
the ratchet mechanism is actually going
to be put to the test
and if two of the world's biggest
emitters china
and india will have higher emissions in
2030 than they did in
2015. how concerned are you that
anything
that is agreed at glasgow will in fact
not be carried out
well i don't think that they're going to
have higher emissions than they had in
2015
uh they are actually on a path to
reducing their emissions but let's
remember
that who has to take the lead here is
industrialized countries
those are the countries that originally
cause climate change
those are the countries that have the
resources and the capacity
to reduce the most and those are the
countries that have the responsibility
and the access to the technologies and
the finance
to actually take the lead so let's look
first at industrialized countries
at what they're doing themselves and how
they're helping
developing countries to get on track
right i mean but there's a lot of sort
of political rhetoric isn't there around
climate change a lot of leaders saying
we must do this and we must do that
um to what extent do you think that
you know now is the time for the
rhetoric to end
and the sort of real change um
to start well i think that is
exactly the question that we should be
asking and for which we want
a uh an an answer because as
secretary general cuthiatz has already
stated this morning
this is there is no longer a denial on
climate change there is no longer
questions whether climate change exists
now we're into a completely new chapter
that establishes the reality
and the threat of climate change and now
what is being called for
is leadership leadership on the part of
politicians leadership on the part of
corporations
leadership on the part of all of us as
individuals because
this is so important and so urgent and
so massive
that the the responsibility cannot be
exported
to anyone else every single human being
right now
independently of what our sphere of
influence is whether that is
a national um influence whether that is
city influence whether that's corporate
insurance or whether it's only family
influence we all have now the very
urgent and huge responsibility
to act in a responsible way to change
our behaviors
and certainly to change the decisions on
investment right and china
we mentioned just now represents 20 to
25
i think it is of all global emissions
and they've pledged carbon neutrality by
2060
um but have yet to put forward any
detailed proposals for how they will get
there does that concern you
they've actually put forward a pledge to
uh be carbon neutral
before 2060 so the before is actually
pretty important
and leave space for them to do what they
usually do which is to
under promise and over deliver which is
quite refreshing compared to
other countries that do exactly the
opposite they are currently
doing their analysis with all of their
constituents to figure out
what uh what additional efforts can they
bring to the table to uh buy cop 26
which is at the end of this year
in uh in the united kingdom so we don't
know yet what china will bring
but all eyes are definitely on china
right and just a quick word on india i
mean
isn't the truth that india is more
concerned about the economy and the
growth of its economy
than it is about climate change
well as as they should be both uh both
of those developing countries and all
other developing countries are very
justifiably concerned
about their development and how they're
going to bring people out of poverty
because that is their first
responsibility the huge
opportunity that they can take advantage
of now is to use
the new technologies clean technology
safer technologies of the 21st century
to do exactly that so they do not have
to choose
between development and alleviation of
poverty they can actually do that
by decarbonizing their economy and by
using the technologies and the financial
instruments that are being developed for
that purpose
okay and just finally uh 20 seconds left
you're a founder of an organization
called global optimism
do you have any optimism left when it
comes to climate
yes i do because frankly we cannot
afford to do
otherwise there is no way that we can
actually close the door
on the possibility that we still have of
addressing climate change
that is our moral responsibility and
frankly it's
actually much better for us so out of
our enlightened self-interest
in addition to morality that is what we
have to do